hey everybody before we get this video
started this video is brought to you by
Trojan h2o closer water-based lubricant
it's natural in a scent and feel and
guess what it's an easy no mess cleanup
Pro she makes living a sexually healthy
lifestyle accessible by creating great
products such as this having the ability
to communicate about sexuality is a
natural part of life yeah hey everybody
welcome to another episode of Real Talk
well we talk real stuff and we go I like
trying to act tough it makes me feel job
anyways I see you out there with your ab
ripper looking all sexy you what a ab
ripple is is where you when you sit down
and you're in your flabs come over and
that's admirable
I got lots of those well everybody in
today's episode we are gonna talk about
love languages and communication and the
reason why we're gonna talk about this
is because there have been a lot of
questions being asked specifically about
you know having a healthy relationship
the reoccurring theme within that are
questions about communication and kind
of getting to know that person that
you're with and this is something that I
have struggled with my whole all right
and remember when we talk about the
stuff in this podcast format and if I
sound a little bit of icy it's not
because I'm telling you what to do per
se I'm telling you stuff that worked for
me and even beyond that I'm also giving
this advice to myself because I still
have to remind myself about these things
on a daily basis so let's just go a
little bit into the type of relationship
person I was before I met Muriel now
before I met Muriel I've only had maybe
like one or two serious relationships it
was my very first girlfriend who broke
my heart AHA and the second girl from
that I was with she cheated on me so
that was that was that was great I will
talk about the whole me being cheated on
in another episode and my first love and
that whole whole series that we kind of
went into but prior to Muriel I didn't
like being in a serious relationship it
wasn't really my thing I I absolutely
hated it and it stemmed from the fact
from the first time I was ever in a
relationship with my first girlfriend
and she completely broke my heart and I
can get into the whole heart ache thing
but the reason why it scared me from
being committed into something is
because when I was with that girl I was
I was a terrible person you know what I
mean I kind of terrible in the sense
that our relationship wasn't healthy we
were too
pletely different people and on top of
that I didn't find value in myself so I
waited every day for that woman that I
was with the tummy that I was fourth or
something so when she didn't tell me I
was worth something or when she left me
I felt like my existence didn't matter
do you have any idea how big of a loser
I was and I think that fear was always
in the back of my mind right I based my
whole existence and my life off of what
somebody else said that I was if she
told me I was a good person if she said
I was a fantastic human being I was like
cool I guess I'm a good person but I
couldn't tell it to myself I mean I
couldn't say it to myself and I wouldn't
believe it even if I did so because of
that experience this is basically what
happened I took myself away from all
these distractions and I said you know
what dude you gotta really focus on
yourself you got to figure out who you
are first before you even think about
getting with somebody else and I did the
problem with that was is that I became
inherently too selfish all I could think
about was me me me me me well yeah it
did help me develop who I was but when
it came time for me to be in a serious
relationship
ie with Muriel it kind of ruined a small
part of it from the first relationship I
learned that I was a damaged human being
and I didn't know what I wanted so I had
to be a bit selfish but in turn I forgot
to grow past that and also learn how to
communicate what I wanted from my
partner and also learn to love them in
the way that they wanted to be loved do
you see what I'm saying so there wasn't
a balance it was just me me me me me and
there wasn't enough hurr hurr hurr hurr
hurr so I couldn't find that strong
medium so this and this for the topic of
love languages comes it now if you
haven't read that book where it talks
about love languages maybe you should
pick it up or if not gonna read a cliff
note about it because even reading a
small excerpt from it will help you
understand how to communicate better
with somebody it's something that's so
apparent but a lot of people don't
practice so how I used to give love and
communicate that love to somebody was by
giving them loved the way that I wanted
to receive it do you know what I mean
it's kind of like when your parents tell
you to do something that they want you
to do because it makes them happy but it
doesn't make you happy and they're
telling you that you should be happy
doing it and it doesn't make sense it
just doesn't click it's like no you are
happy because I'm doing what you're
telling me to do but you're not really
asking me what may
me happy and a lot of us do that and you
don't know that you're doing it at all
and the only thing that you see is that
hey I'm giving you love I'm giving you
love why don't you feel loved it's like
we hold off for a second dude you're not
giving her love you're actually giving
yourself love in disguise
you're telling them that they should
feel loved the way that you want them to
feel it and that's where that
communication breaks down so for me when
it comes to my love language my love
language is the first and foremost
important thing is physical touch so for
me my love languages communicate when
Muriel comes up to me she gives me hugs
she holds my hand so when we first
started going out like I you know I gave
her love the way that I thought that she
wanted I gave him kisses on the chin I
kissed her hand I held her hand I did
all that other stuff but what she wanted
and what she needed in the relationship
was verbal affirmation my god this
woman's love language is verbal
affirmation to the max and you know like
when you give somebody their love
language to you have to do it
wholeheartedly and I had the biggest
issue with that even after I read the
damn book you know what I'm talking
about where they want verbal affirmation
for something that they think that they
did awesome but you don't think it's
that dope so you're just like hey great
baby good job and it's not really fair
is it because once again you're also
trying to give that person their love
looking is the way that they want but
you're still trying to sneak in the way
you want to do it so you're really not
giving it to them full heartedly so if
you're asking what those five love
languages are I don't know off the top
of my head anymore but let's just go
through that list it's going to be words
of affirmation physical touch receiving
gifts quality times and acts of service
here and tell you guys what each one is
if you guys really want to know go
online and you can see for yourself and
it'll be amazing what's going to happen
you are really going to figure out like
holy crap I guess I really am one of
these five right and then it's not just
like so black and white where it's just
you know it's just the one and you don't
feel anything else it kind of goes like
ingredients it's like well this is my
number one this is two three four and
five to go but to go back to Muriel and
the whole love language and
communication thing was I had to learn
how to do things full-heartedly once
again it's because
giving somebody their love language and
not meaning it probably hurts more than
just not giving it to them at all
because it's kind of like a like a slap
to the face or kind of like a backhanded
complicated I had a conversation with
Bart and you know when I was telling him
about giving that person that love
language and doing things the way that
they want to I wasn't really talking to
him I was talking to myself because I
don't do it and I'm learning I'm really
learning how to do it well you know
instead of doing it the David sell way
which is I mean I guess I'm learning
this basic part of communication in your
relationship is going to help you a lot
I guarantee you and not just from like
just conversation wise but I'm talking
about in the bed too son
I know there's a lot of dudes out there
that think their penis game is like you
know what it's on point this is what I
do every girl might see bro if you are
one of those people out there that talk
about your possible as if it's like
God's gift to women I guarantee you you
probably ain't just laying in it right
I'm not saying that I'm that great at it
but you know what I've had a lot of
women tell me David you suck and I fixed
it so if you guys are having problem
with communicating with your partner
show them this video let's have a
conversation about it and on top of that
try this out with somebody just ask the
person that you're with how do you want
me to communicate love to you and how
would I like to receive love as well it
goes both ways
and let me know how it works out for you
guys because I'm telling you it helped
me out a lot like I learned I can get
into this a little more but I need water
hey what is going on YouTube thank you
once again chose you for sponsoring this
video if you guys have any topics
comments questions articles just
subjects anything that you want me to
talk about we're gonna be doing a lot
more of these real talks and these open
podcast things I know a lot of people
want me to do a podcast where I bring on
a guest that might be something in the
future but this is way easier for me to
do you guys already know I'm writing TV
shows movies I've got businesses that
I'm running but I don't want to leave
you guys so let's make it happen I love
you so much
excuse me in my chest bone what